meanwhile in washington democrats are
working on details of a compromised
spending plan that they think will be
able to pass the president is busy
trying to sell that scaled back
blueprint to the american public now
campaigning yesterday in scranton
pennsylvania where he was born nancy
cordes is at the white house for us
nancy the president is trying to sell
this thing how's it going
well tony we have started to witness a
big change in tone from democrats just
in the past 24 hours or so they are
beginning to predict that the party
could reach an internal agreement in the
next 24 hours 48 hours certainly by the
end of the week on a bill that could
come to define the biden presidency
i'm hopeful i think we'll get a good
deal from the president on down
wednesday democrats began to express
optimism it's moving in the right
direction we're all feeling very
positive about the coming together
coming together meant coming to terms
with eliminating big chunks of the
president's original 3.5 trillion dollar
proposal free community college gone
housing assistance reduced paid family
leave cut from a proposed 12 weeks to as
few as four are you confident that
family leave will stay in our
reconciliation package that's what we
want for now the roughly 450 billion
dollars for child care subsidies and
universal pre-k appear to be safe so is
the child tax credit though it may only
get extended for one year instead of
four
but there's a new fight looming over how
to pay for all this democrats had
planned to do it by raising taxes on the
wealthy and corporations but arizona's
kirsten cinema is reportedly bulking at
that plan in scranton pennsylvania
yesterday president biden insisted it
will all get worked out this has been
declared dead on arrival from the moment
i introduced it but i think we're going
to surprise them
because i think people are beginning to
figure out what's at stake
one of the big challenges for democrats
in this final stretch has been that they
don't really know where senator cinema
stands because she hasn't made her views
public but she insists she has been
sharing those views in her multiple
meetings that she's held here at the
white house gail
all right the meetings in the
conversation continues thank you very
much nancy